حصلت CNN أيضًا على صوت من
الإرسال، ونريد مرة أخرى أن نحذرك
من أنه يبدو الأمر مزعجًا
كما لو أنهم حصلوا على
مطلق نار شرعي نشط في مدرسة جميع الوحدات تكون
تحت قناع وقد تلقت تنبيهًا بوجود العديد من
الضحايا
ونحن نتعلم المزيد عن
المهاجم على  في هذه الساعة، هذا ما
نعرفه الآن، وقد وصفت الشرطة أودري هيل البالغة من العمر 28 عامًا
بأنها متحولة جنسيًا من أنثى إلى ذكر، وكانت قد
التحقت سابقًا بالمدرسة، ونحن نتلقى
معلومات جديدة تمامًا هذا الصباح
وفقًا لما ذكره موقع wtvf التابع لنا، حيث
تواصل مطلق النار مع أحد
زميلة سابقة في المدرسة الإعدادية في حوالي الساعة 9:57 صباحًا قبل
دقائق فقط من الطلقات الأولى، ثم
قال ذلك الشخص إن هيل أرسلت لها رسالة
على إنستغرام مفادها أن هيل خططت للموت
بالانتحار وأنها ستشاهد ذلك في
الأخبار
يومًا ما، وهذا سيكون أكثر منطقية.  لقد
تركت وراءها ما يكفي من الأدلة
ولكن شيئًا سيئًا على وشك
الحدوث، الرسالة المذكورة الآن
تقول هذا الشخص لـ wtvf إنها اتصلت بالشرطة
في الساعة 10:13 صباحًا، وفي تلك المرحلة كان إطلاق النار قد
بدأ بالفعل